hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast genomes for medicine
my name is hop hinder from Illumina and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth for more information please
visit lab routes comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
the webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them into the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
the green Q&A button on the lower left
of the presentation window we'll try and
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower
right-hand of the side window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button on the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problems through the green Q&A
button on your left this is an
educational webinar and this offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the C e
button located on the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce our today's
speaker and David Bentley today vyd is
the vice president and chief scientist
at Illumina he has played a leading role
in human gene in the human genome
project and related international
consortium incineration including the
snip consortium perhaps that project and
the hapmap project his long term
interest is the study of human sequence
variation and its impact on human health
and disease his current research focuses
on fast accurate sequencing of human
genomes and adoption and benefit in
healthcare with early applications
including rare genetic disease and
cancer these applications are
exemplified in the goals of the hundred
thousand genomes project a partnership
that includes Illumina genomics England
and the NHS England with that a very
warm welcome to David and to everyone
listening I hope you will enjoy the
presentation
thank you very much Hardman for that
kind of deduction like to have my
welcome to everybody who is present for
this seminar today and I'll get right to
it I'm particularly keen to share with
you some of the insights that we have
gained as a result of collaborations
which have really been geared towards
improving human health by unlocking the
power of the genome it really stems from
the Human Genome Project the sequence
released from that and how we can put it
to good use
ultimately in in medical applications as
well as research I'll deal with four
parts I will briefly go through some
concepts which underlie this work I
would describe something of a recent
technology developments of how we
monitor what's going on touch on working
at scale which is particularly linked to
the hundred thousand genome project and
other projects around the world a
similar scale and finally just draw a
few conclusions to stimulate further
questions and thoughts so let me start
with concepts for some time I think this
vision of precision medicine has been
evolving and I think it's exemplified by
this slide it's a vision shared by many
organizations and it starts if you will
at the bottom of the slide by the
patient this is the timeline of an
individual as they go through life from
birth indeed from conception and you can
see through the timeline a series of
events that take place throughout this
person's life unfortunately this person
gets cancer at one point during their
life and you can see a series of events
which take place in the course of
managing or relapsing and ultimately the
death of the individual as a result of
the cancer on the bottom of the line you
see a number of different areas of
different colors and these that indicate
points at which we can make measurements
of the individual clinical observations
or molecular measurements or sequence
information which can be collected at
various points throughout a person's
life and they serve as important metrics
to correlate with the clinical
observations and the disease so that we
can understand better what the readout
of a patient from their blood samples
from their DNA or for whatever it may be
how they correlate with our
understanding and our ability to either
assess diagnose or indeed provide a
prognosis for patients and by exploring
in detail a patient such as this we can
then extrapolate that information
for benefit to future patients like them
as you can see the patient information
is optimally accumulated in a
knowledgebase possibly in a cloud or a
private cloud and that information
should then be available to support
research on the Left individuals can
access the data to support new findings
new discoveries and on the right by
clinicians directly perhaps to help them
in their treatment choice or other
aspects of managing the patient's
condition and this whole ecosystem is
one which is a long-term program a
collaborative venture with with
different countries and different
organizations but the vision is
essentially the same and it's a very
shared vision across the world let me
start with the concept which has really
introduced the use of whole genome
sequencing for genetic diagnosis this is
not entirely about whole genome
sequencing but my talk will focus
predominantly on whole genome sequencing
and mention other of a sequencing
methods as appropriate we have an
undiagnosed condition a male child
presents with developmental regression
to two unaffected parents and
essentially the concept is that by a
sequencing the genome of this individual
in this case in a four-day turnaround
time which is a clinically relevant to
turnaround time we can gain the complete
information from live individuals genome
which is potentially responsible for
what looks like a genetic condition this
is how we then filter through the whole
genome from looking at the 3 billion
bases or 3 million variants or so we can
examine transcripts with how particular
variants which may be of interest and
gradually filter down by asking
additional generic questions of the
genome for example we're expecting two
variants were expecting a very low
frequency mutation in the population we
can predict function and we can examine
whether a gene is previously known to be
involved in a disease and as you can see
there is as you go through these various
questions you very quickly filter down
in almost real-time a few clicks of the
mouse will actually lead you to a few
and sometimes one a really strong
candidate which is a mutation which is
an irrelevant gene with a relevant
function and the important thing there
is to correlate that that variant with
the condition to confirm the diagnosis
and this particular
illustration here is of a normal variant
which correlated both of the genetics
and the apparent function of that gene
which led to a diagnosis collaboration
was stealing Kingsmore who is now at the
radio genome Center
so this illustrated the application of
whole genome sequencing it equally the
model applies very well for whole exome
sequencing as well from doing a
genome-wide search to find a point
mutation which causes disease and offer
a diagnosis which is a great benefit to
the family so look at how this applies
more broadly I show you here a table of
several studies which have really
embraced that same method that same
approach and you can see here that these
we've moved from single anecdotes which
were reported as one offs or n of one
cases through to looking at small or
middle sized cohorts now to examine how
often does this paradigm actually hold
and you can see here that from a single
test from a whole genome or whole exome
they lumped together in this set we are
looking at not one or two but we're
looking at 25 and 30 and in some cases
over 50% of the cases of previously
undiagnosed conditions are actually
amenable to interpretation and diagnosis
by this remote method and this
illustrates the potentially important
powerful nature of the universal test
looking at the whole genome and seeing
how we can apply it to these clinical
diagnosis of different clinical types
moving on to cancer for a moment as I
mentioned this is another early interest
a similar anecdote reported here
illustrates that in this case a
recurrent glioblastoma which was not
responding to treatments was actually
biopsied and sampled in this case three
biopsies were sampled again in the
clinically relevant turnaround time this
is actually 10 day turnaround to get the
three results and one of the interesting
things about this case is not only the
clinical turnaround time was again
relevant to the management of the
condition we returned the data back
before the patient was ready for
treatment but also in particular in this
case we found not so much single
nucleotide changes and I'm talking here
about somatic changes in the tumor DNA
as compared to the normal DNA we saw in
this case copy number variants
throughout the genome as well as other
variants and you can see here in
particular one of those popular variants
really amplified a particularly
important gene
involved in growth control and in fact
several CNB's are actually amplified
several genes involved in the same
signaling pathway and this is
illustrated here while the important
points here of course is that as you
find mutations in the genome without a
prior hypothesis you suddenly find not
one but several hits on a particular
biologically important function but you
also find that you are essentially
suddenly harnessing years and years of
biological research that has gone into
understanding the signaling pathway and
immediately that information is accessed
and made available to benefit the
interpretation of this patient and you
can see here these three genes which
were amplified in the genome among other
mutations all lead to stimulating and
over stimulating the same signaling
pathway which leads to cancer moreover a
very important finding from this pathway
is actually in looking up the available
drugs you can actually see there but not
one but actually there are three
fda-approved drugs already available all
of which would act to block this pathway
and none of which had been used
previously on this particular case so
this really embraces the paradigm that
sequencing of a tumor can actually
potentially inform therapy and this
echos the original thymus paradigm was
was put forward by Mark O'Mara
back in 2009 this particular
collaboration with Charlie Swanson in
the CI UK in here in London looking on
to other aspects of whole genome
sequencing cancer is a complex condition
I want to show you a few examples of
other collaborations where we have
explored different readouts from the
same whole genome sequence data which
reflects on our description or our
characterization of the condition this
example here is a collaboration with
Newcastle where we use whole genome
sequencing of acute lymphocytic leukemia
ALL samples and in this case we show the
high hyper diploid II which is a
characteristic of some childhood al L
and it's indeed an indicator good
progress a simple readout and
alternative to such genetic testing in
this example we use whole genome
sequencing at multiple time points in
the course of a chronic lymphocytic
leukemia and this reveals two things you
can see in the first two time points
essentially a different subclonal
popular
Asians can be identified from the whole
genome somatic mutation profile and the
red sub population dominates by the time
this next treatment is given and is
largely removed by a successful response
to the treatment as you see in the Third
Point when you look ahead to the fourth
and fifth time points um a few months
later in the ins life you can see a
remission which is characterized by a
reexpansion of subclonal populations but
in this case a different sub clonal
population characterized by a different
profile of somatic mutations is now
arisen ironically however at the time
when we sequence the patient when it was
deemed to be in remission you could
actually see from the sequence data that
we carried out the whole genome sequence
that already the new profile of sub
clonal populations was expanding just at
the time when the patient was declared
well and clearly in this case then if
you looked at the molecular signature
and you would not conclude that this
patient was exactly in remission
clinical remission maybe the symptoms
were alleviated but the disease is
already present at the molecular level
and this would have been an opportunity
to intervene earlier with the benefits
of molecular data so this just
illustrates there a time course of a
cancer patient where we can use sequence
information and the somatic mutation
profiles both to to alter our
understanding of the remission and look
in general at the response of the
individual to particular treatment I'll
come back to that concept in a moment
but I wanted to move on just for a
second to a couple of signatures again
the opportunity to look at the entire
genome and all the mutations in the
cancer at a particular time point
sometimes reveals particular context
this particular example shown here is in
example of two contexts from two
patients where a majority of C to T
changes in pyrimidine dimers typically
is a signal of the exposure to UV light
and this is essentially of course a
precursor to skin cancer or a mechanism
by which skin cancer arises on the top
you see a signature which is different
if you pulled all the mutations in us in
a case which has been exposed to
cigarette smoke and these signatures are
both essentially embedded in the somatic
mutation profiles which can be extracted
and characterized quite quantitatively
once you have a whole genome or a genome
my data set of all these mutations you
really can look at the signatures of the
exposure to the environmental factors
which gave rise to the cancer which may
be useful information or you can also
see signatures of defective DNA repair
and other mechanisms which again may be
relevant in terms of at least assessing
the prognosis for that further cancer
it's important to understand these is a
research finding at this stage but the
availability of such information and
making it readily available I will
return to at the end of this
presentation but making it readily
available is important if we are to
understand better how to use such
genomic information in clinical reports
and interpreting an individual's
molecular profile for the benefit to the
patient another example is that
signatures both the last one and the
present one in this case come from Mike
Stratton's group at the Sanger Institute
just nearby this is an example where
looking across an entire genome you see
all the mutations somatic mutations
plotted across the entire genome but you
see one area of the genome where there
really has been a catastrophic event
katti giuse these are called rain
rainfall plots and this is a rainfall or
a cloud burst if you will at the part of
a chromosome which has really been hit
by one particularly mutation type and
this is in a breaker one mutated tumor
breast cancer and clearly this
information is not necessarily available
from standard test and traditional tests
it's a new kind of readout but we can
learn whether we can find this
information useful in amending our
diagnosis consider if you've done a
somatic panel you would see in a few
mutations and you'd returned a verdict
on this breast cancer but you completely
missed this catastrophic event unless
you have a genome-wide test such as a
whole genome or in some cases a whole
exome another important finding just is
to reflect on this for a moment because
as you move outside the the genes it's
the non-coding mutations also play a
very important role in in in the
derivation of cancer this is a
well-known example where whole genome
sequencing as opposed to exome
sequencing reveals formation of a novel
transcription factor in the in the 13
and actually leads to in this case a
mutation which when you survey other
examples of melon
you actually find not only is this
mutation present in other melanomas but
is present actually at the same
frequency as the very well-known b-raf
v600e mutation so these non-coding
mutations are not edge phases they are
essentially going to contribute very
significantly to our increased ability
to understand and interpret individual
cancer cases and indeed potentially to
classify them as a prerequisite to
possibly include improving the
management of the condition one more
paradigm I'll just involved for you is
the diagnostic yield which I showed for
the rare genetic disease that we're
moving from anecdotes to a quantitative
number of cases that we're actually you
can characterize them here is an example
an early example from from the AL L
study where our 22% of all ll cases are
unexplained at the molecular level at
the beginning of this study they're
either completely normal or some
unexplained apparent rearrangement by
sighted genetic testing and this
collaboration again by Newcastle we
actually took the entire fraction of the
unexplained cases of the molecular level
and actually found an insightful
mutation multiple new genes were
identified in every one of them by whole
genome sequencing and so effective the
diagnostic yield or the detection of
clinically relevant mutations some of
which are still undergoing further
validation of course and functional
proof but nevertheless are very
compelling mutations in in ninety seven
percent of these new cases of 99% over
all available cases through a single
whole genome sequencing test do provide
a very compelling mutation to aid the
interpretation of the condition and this
is one of the important measures in any
approach where we're trying to improve
the precision in genomic medicine
whether it's through a whole genome or
whole exome or other approaches is to
look at the yield of results the
diagnostic information that is relevant
and in turn in a case of cancer the kind
of information that may be relevant to
treatment in the future one more
paradigm is not directly about whole
genome sequencing but it does indicate
that if you have the whole genome
sequence characterized from a particular
patient
it provides a rich source of information
about that patients to personalize the
follow-up process
and you can see here for example a
mutation and EGFR gene of this
particular lung cancer patient this lung
cancer patient responded to treatment
with the officially banned you can see
the reduction in circulating tumor DNA
carrying this mutation from 14 percent
down to less than one percent over a
period of two months and you can see the
corresponding images in the lung of the
individual on the top what you then find
in monitoring the patient with the same
personalized test that was derived from
the whole genome you actually see it
sadly a remit a relapse but you can see
the measurement of the relapse is
quantitative and accurate such that some
were just approaching one year later the
mutation is now present again in the
individual circulating tumor DNA 1% and
then sadly over the following six months
elevates to a very high level 49%
concomitant both with the regrowth of
the original tumor and also additional
metastasis so this just illustrates not
only the value of having extensive
mutation profile somatic mutation
profile of a patient the ability to use
it in follow-up tests which are highly
targeted highly personalized it also
begins to hint at this ecosystem once
again an integrated system whereby you
can actually use different methods to
apply an understand and better measure
the progression of cancer in a patient
at different times during their life I'd
like to move on now to briefly discuss
some of the technology aspects that
we've been working on that are highly
relevant there growing points in the
curve first of all clearly technology
itself the actual generation of sequence
data is a very important driver in this
whole field it was a disruptive change
in data rate when we first developed the
iluminage system based on this alexa
chemistry and you can see here in recent
years we've continued to use various
tools going to patterned surfaces faster
cameras improved and faster chemistry to
increase the data rate which is the
overall measure by which we're really
trying to characterize these genomes and
you can see a leap there between 2013
and 2014 which was no accident
this was not just a major technology
improvement and this was the launch of
the high seek pecks but it was also
stimulated a development program that
are stimulated because of the perceived
need in the community and the appetite
for moving to larger amounts of sequence
and taking whole genome sequencing on up
to whole genome levels and to population
scale one of the major impacts of course
is that as a result of the increased
data rate then the the actual cost of
the experiment goes down significantly
and you can see here the concomitant
reduction in the whole genome sequencing
achieving in 2014 this rather iconic
number of a thousand dollar genome which
is for an essential 30x average depth
genome but it does reflect a very
important trigger point for many
people's thinking when previously
sequencing was very expensive among
other the other limitations here it is
now reduced to something which is very
manageable meaningful in terms of
healthcare budgets or per capita budgets
I wanted to return for a moment to the
question of whole genomes I've
emphasized the use of whole genomes that
is not to the exclusion of other methods
I've already shown you a targeted
sequencing process but this just
summarizes a few points which are worthy
of discussion as to why one would focus
on whole genomes or why we focus on
whole genomes and why this also
resonated with genomics England and a
number of other collaborators and
projects that we are now involved in it
is of course the complete accurate
genetic makeup of an individual it is
one test single test near complete
characterization and individuals genomic
information once and for all in the case
of germline and a cancer of course the
genome is dynamic and these resampling
as I've already showed you just to
explain the second bullet recapitulating
the principle of the human genome
project itself the human genome project
in the early stages went through a big
debate as to whether to sequence the
entire genome or just look at the
transcripts and clearly if we'd only
sequence the transcripts we would not
have 98% of the information the same
thing is actually true here in secretive
individuals whole genome it really does
provide all the information that is
likely to be contributing to a condition
even if his pocket understood and I
showed you the promoter mutations and
the Terr gene already they would come
naturally in that whole genome
sequencing test it's also technically
simple a point which is perhaps not
necessarily widely grasped as yet
it's a highly reproducible high quality
product I've been a straight to the
trade-offs there although of course
there is a question of cost data volume
to be handled and I'll touch on that in
a moment and the number of samples that
can be processed either in a time or in
a particular capacity in terms of what
is the appropriate way and the table at
the bottom there illustrates just a
brief comparison of the kind of
information you can get on the level of
completeness of the information you can
get from a panel from an XML from a
genome in particular there as well as
coding variants of course coming from
Vienna from the region that's targeted
but the non-coding variants are
restricted to the genome and and the
exome less well than the genome will
also detect rather complex genetic
events consanguinity uniparental dice
semi some of these events have already
proved extremely important in amending a
diagnosis for an individual one of the
challenges are moving from basic
research to clinical space of course is
that we are dealing with real-world
samples and just rather schematically
where they illustrate it here blood
samples have been really been the bread
and butter of source of DNA for many
tests and of course that is now emulated
further with the use of cell free DNA
for precise tests but illustrated also
two other ones in particular the use of
FFPE DNA DNA which comes from
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tissue
which is in blocks which is extremely
suboptimal way of treating DNA although
it's very good for histology but this
has become a major source potentially of
tumor DNA samples this DNA is degraded
it is modified it is damaged and so we
have to look at modifying protocols to
see how effectively we can actually
generate data or whether targeted or
whole genome from FFP material I'll just
show you a slide on that in one second
the other which I won't show any more on
of course is biopsies are very important
as a currency for collecting samples
from individuals and these of course
only provide very small amounts
DNA so it's very important that we
continue to learn how to work with
smaller and smaller amounts of material
while still getting that all-important
highly representative genome sequence
data this slide just illustrates some
current work collaboration with genomics
England in working out how to improve
whole genome sequencing metope samples
this is a direct comparison between what
you see as a whole genome readout from a
fresh frozen sample that's the gold
standard from in this case a solid tumor
and you can see a varying read depth and
some indication of variants in there
when you look at the same tumor which
has been embedded in fresh in
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded
material you can see here a much lumpy R
read depth plot and the B allele
frequency plots are much less distinct
really difficult or impossible to make
any call about copy number variants from
this sample but my amending the DNA
extraction process and this is one of a
number of steps you can see the same
sample of exactly the same sample can be
returned to something which is closely
resembling not quite but closely
resembling the quality of the fresh
frozen sample and this sort of research
gives some hope that we can actually
learn how better to extract DNA from
FFPE samples so that we can get valuable
information not just from the single
nucleotide variants and the small in
bells which come through this but also
the copy number variants and structural
variants are much more likely to be well
read out from such modifications this is
just shows an example of developing
extraction methods that improve the
extraction of the DNA in a separate part
of this collaboration all the upfront
methods for fixing the tissue in the
first place in embedding are also
undergoing review and it may be entirely
possible to amend or improve the early
stages of this process to the benefit of
the DNA quality that comes out without
compromising the histology information
which is also important so watch this
space
FFP certainly has been a challenge but
we get good whole genomes from a wide
fraction of the whole genome of the FFPE
samples moving back into more
fundamental metrics of the genome for a
moment this illustrates where we keep a
very close eye on the
quality of the coverage and the bias in
every genome essentially what you want
as far as possible is that the whole
genome data you get out is a faithful
representation of the DNA that went in
that came from the patient and each of
these blocks of bars here illustrates
various segments of the genome that are
monitored genes and exons are the first
two blocks and then there are some
difficult regions high GC regions
regions which are known to be poorly
recovered in certain protocols and you
can see that over the ages as we go from
left to right within each of the blocks
we move from our classic amplified
sample prep to a PCR free prep and we
actually reduce the amount of starting
material required but at the same time
we are increasing the proportionate
representation of those difficult
regions so they're coming much closer to
the the normalized one which you see at
the top of this plot one means that if
you build a 30x genome you would get on
average a 30x representation of that
particular feature so you can see for
example a very high gc-rich ones they're
not up to one yet but they're getting
close to 0.7 times what you would expect
from a random sampling and so this is
very encouraging in terms of getting
really good coverage across most of the
genome but it's an area that we really
look at particularly these difficult
areas promoters are gc-rich but we
really want to see promoters and you can
see how far we've come
key drivers are the PC are free I've
mentioned improved quality of the
chemistry reducing the load DNA input
and I've already mentioned the use of
FFP for a more visual picture of this
concept you see here an IG B plot
integrated genome Bua plot of the same
genome done in three different ways
there are two different amplification
protocols which worked pretty well the
Nano versus version 1 and version 2 and
this is across a very gc-rich
exon exon to the ARX gene which is
important in medical conditions but you
can see here the adoption went at PC our
free protocol at the bottom does
actually allow this very gc-rich exon to
be represented in the genome and so you
can see the effect of just looking at
these very small put points in the
genome which may be medically relevant
and are also very important to actually
assess how well
they are represented in the whole genome
are all part of making a whole genome or
other methods really tested and able to
provide the information that is really
required in the clinic accuracy is
another important area and I won't go
into this in great detail there's a
whole presentation on accuracy but I do
want to mention this project just in
passing wherefore it makes it important
to actually be able to objectively
compare different analysis pipelines in
adopting ones which are suitable for the
project and this illustrates a project
that we developed in order to make that
objective assessment it's called the
platinum genome project it's a public
reference data set we generate a deep
sequence coverage of whole genomes of
each of the individuals in that
three-generation pedigree and we
identified five million essentially high
quality variants as a truth set and we
identify them at the truth set because
the variants are entirely consistent
across every member of the pedigree
so the inheritance test from one or two
other tests essentially passes or fails
of areas being flattened in quality and
once we have the Platinum Barons set we
can then utilize genome sequence data
and different pipelines to evaluate how
well different pipelines call or do not
call the Platinum variants set and the
bottom table illustrates our
straightforward comparison between the
high seek analysis software it's an
earlier version in fact for the B 3 and
gatk and you can see the recall and
precision of either the single based
substitution calls and the IND in small
in Dells 1 to 50 bases is essentially
comparable you can examine the
differences between them but the other
very important point about this is that
the reason that the high seek analysis
software suite was written was in order
to cope with the challenge of scale
because you can see here that a whole
genome is actually analyzed in five
hours as opposed to 38 by the gatk a
suite of software and this becomes
extremely important when we're looking
at working at scale which I'll just
touch on a bit later and these these
performance criteria were measured on an
equivalent
hardware platform one thing that is
emerged from the Platinum Genome Project
was to actually see clusters of snips
which appeared to fail the Mendelian
pattern and clearly there's something
else at stake here
if multiples snv's in one location of
the genome appear to have Mendelian
conflicts and this illustrates one such
area and actually what the what the the
reason for these this cluster of snips
are having a Mendelian conflict is that
in actual fact there's a previously
undetected underlying cnv which
essentially and the rejects reveals this
transmitted deletion in the mother this
foot is right onto looking in
populations more broadly at the same
events because being able to detect a
lot more of these complex variants cnv
structural variants and so on is really
important if we're trying to build up a
complete picture of the spectrum of
variants in our genomes so that we can
then in turn refine the algorithms to
improve their detection and the bottom
part of this slide I'll just pick out
the very bottom track for a moment this
same region in a population of 2000
Caucasian individuals these snips all
show a departure from hardy-weinberg
equilibrium with an excess of
heterozygotes sorry in excess of
homozygous which is entirely consistent
with the same previously undetected
deletion being prevalent in the
population this is moving ahead the
slides here
okay let me move on so one other
important area which is is is focus for
medical relevant is the detection of
repeat expansions these pleace
expansions may not be so relevant in a
whole genome wide context but of course
in certain conditions fragile x-linked
mental retardation ALS myotonic
dystrophy and Huntington's these small
repeat sequences that expand and move
from a pre-symptomatic anticipation to
an actual affected individual are very
important and one might at first glance
consider that hexamer or triplet repeats
cannot be detected by by by short reads
in fact they can and this actually
underlies a very important principle on
the left here you see a whole series of
individuals previously typed as positive
for expansion in ALS condition and we
detect 95% of the by analysis of the
short reads correspondingly the normal
some thirteen hundred and twenty three
unaffected individuals revealed on the
whole by our test in the whole genome
sequence data also an unaffected
individual with the exception of three
which were subsequently retested and
actually found to be positive so the
test is extremely sensitive and specific
for detecting repeat expansions
this is an important aspect of examining
more closely medically important regions
of a genome to be able to analyze them
in whole genome sequence what's also
very important however is that this
reflects a fundamental principle where
in order to identify repeat sequences we
were not looking at the reads that are
aligned to the genome we were looking at
the unaligned reads that are also
present in every bam file but are not
necessarily analyzed or would not be
analyzed in a normal process of using an
alignment and therefore these reads are
a rich source of other information about
rearrangements in an individual genome
and they're quite amenable to
characterization and we can write
algorithms to extract information such
as what you see on this slide and at the
same time then you can incorporate those
algorithms into the pipeline so we're
extracting much more information about
CNB's junction fragments and these
repeat expansions in whole genome
sequence data these algorithms have yet
to be folded in in most cases to the
pipelines but this illustrates just one
of the growing points in our research
and this is all in collaboration with
various clinical and molecular
investigators around the world
I said I'd touch on on data footprint
and one of the much-discussed elements
of whole genome sequencing and indeed
any population scale sequencing is the
scale of the information in the amount
of data this illustrates the important
concept is shrinking the data footprint
we start with an assembled genome a 30x
depth genome which is a BAM file on the
Left 120 gig of data we can do sparest
things and we have in collaboration with
the EBI and other organizations taken
steps to reduce the granularity of the
information in this case reduced quality
score bins to drink it to 80 gig and
then compression techniques largely
developed in this case of the EBI the
crammed formula which provides a 30g
version of the original 120 g genome
looking further beyond this however we
look to the actual concept of extracting
the information from the consensus and
not storing all the reads and once you
wrote you take the consensus as read and
you examine and carve is all the
variants you form a VCF these are
actually GB CFS and I don't have time to
go into the G and the importance of the
G except to say that these GB CF s--
store information on every variant for
future clinical interpretation that they
also store information on the quality of
every homozygous call in the entire
genome and this is very important to be
able to call if there is definitely not
a variant in a particular position
that's a very important piece of
information to know in the clinic to be
able to say you definitely do not have a
mutation in this exon as opposed to
saying I can't see a mutation in the
exon
so the GB CF is a really important
currency very lightweight to gig of
information sufficient for interpreting
annotating interpreting the genome but
it does cover the entire genome not just
the variants so these last two forms the
two gig files
GBCs with annotation of course make the
genome very
portable and easy to transfer and this
arguably is the real currency going
forward of genomes and I've just
outlined there perhaps the two preferred
forms of data which might become
long-term you might see a long-term
storage of the crammed files to archive
and perhaps look up and go back but
really the annotated G VCF that the 2gig
file you can get many of them on a thumb
drive and transport them they can be
uploaded and downloaded and so this is
really the common currency of the genome
it's important to recognize that
drinking the data footprint has not lost
you any information about the variants
or about the the homozygous reference
calls in the entire genome this really
is a portable genome which really
resolves many of the challenges about
data storage going forward I mentioned
annotation in passing once again there's
much to be said about capturing publicly
available and eyesore license
information from research cohorts and
from local aggregation this helps to
improve Disease Association information
and in particular the feature here is
that we've done a great deal to work
with vep and related annotation engines
but actually reduced the time again from
12 hours of genome to 3 minutes and from
10 gig 2.5 gigabytes of space storage
required per genome so once again it's
important to have very comprehensive
annotation but like the actual analysis
before it it's important to be able to
do it in a time scale and with the
amount of storage that is commensurate
with working at very large scale I just
want to touch on some recently sold
cases because we want to get back to the
clinic for a moment and this illustrates
how some of the technological advances
I've just been describing have had a
real impact on diagnosis of rare genetic
disease and these are just anecdotes but
they serve to illustrate the point these
came through our Clinical Laboratory in
San Diego where we do an undiagnosed
disease sequencing service and we do
include all the interpretation and
report generation which is signed off by
our board-certified geneticist here's
one example of an autism like symptoms
and a one
year-old we're actually the answers
found in a gene that was not previously
known to be involved in such a condition
but the genome-wide approach enabled us
to actually chase and identify such a
mutation and de novo dominant mutation
in this particular case the second is
one where a nine year old have had a
complex condition from one year and it
turned out that a really strong
candidate gene for which there was
previously nothing had been seen because
we were now able to see CME's copy
number variants we were able to find in
this very compelling a candidate gene a
fifty-five kilobase copy Lamba variant
which indeed turned out to be a dominant
effect in this condition and the third
example is one of a compound het a
recessive condition but here once again
the single base mutation had been
revealed from an earlier analysis but
actually going back and now being able
to look for CNVs and we actually showed
that the other chromosome was suffering
a deletion and as a result the gene was
entirely knocked out in this particular
condition this is compelling not only
because it illustrates we're
incorporating the ability to detect
CNB's better increases the ability to
explain cases it increases the
diagnostic yield but also in this case
this last case was a 16 year old and for
16 years this family had not had an
answer and actually providing a
confirmed diagnosis really does a great
deal to help counsel the family and
really change their lives for the better
even if they can't do much about the
actual condition itself I'm touching on
this interpretation reporting process as
we move towards scale and this is
something of a preview to just talking
briefly about working at scale
sequencing the genome and annotating is
is now becoming fairly well automated
fairly well scaled but the question of
interpretation reporting remains a very
individual process requiring expert
examination and you can see from this
chart when we started the process in May
that in May 2013 that it was taking
something like 40 hours per case to
interpret some 1,500 genes looking at
all the incidental findings and
your potential candidates much of which
was to do with the curation and
re-examination of literature and some of
which was to do with generating the
report which is the blue pit on the top
and you can see over this period in 2013
and since then we progressively reduced
the time it takes by taking away all the
unnecessary steps which individuals were
doing manually to gradually automate and
also very importantly to log findings in
a database so they can be looked up next
time round if they come again and this
is the concept of the knowledge base
very actual knowledge base for
interpreting genomes and you can see
that today we're down at less than 10
hours a case for a pretty comprehensive
interpretation and now this is our
starting point for really continuing to
build with collaborations and with
hopefully sourcing national experts and
international experts the whole idea of
a curation knowledge base could become
much more powerful and further reduced
that figure so that genomes really can
be interpreted still with the manual
inspection and manual intervention but
at the same time in a much more
accelerated progress so that if we're
generating genomes at a rate of knots
that they really commensurate with a
number of cases in the population we
actually do have the ability to
interpret and return results through
this gradual improvement automation
curation of knowledge and the ability to
make all this information accessible to
the geneticists and other experts
appropriately as an example and I'm just
going to tie in both the first and
second part of this talk for a moment
how do you present the information in a
way which is really accessible to a
commission this is an example of an
automated report I've actually chosen a
cancer example here but the rare genetic
disease ones approach better known but
they're also more familiar to people but
you can see here we can analyze somatic
mutations in cancer in the same way by
essentially highlighting genes we know
to be important here I think ATM and p53
as a mutation in this particular
colorectal patient in these genes a
somatic mutation and there are also some
other mutations were about which we know
less but nevertheless we highlight them
as potentially suspicious worthy of
follow-up a worthy of
they're annotation but on the right-hand
side of this report which is a prototype
report we also include tools that
actually visualize all the other more
complex graphical information I showed
you from the very beginning of this
presentation you can actually show in
the same report a complete spectrum of
copy number variants gross changes the
context of sequences in case there's
something specific about DNA repair
defects or something a clue about the
environmental exposures and the bottom
is that rainfall plot to look for
contagious events that may be relevant
and should not be ignored so if you have
both halves of this report you really
are in possession of a much more
complete picture of an individual's
cancer genome than if you are simply
working with small mutations and trying
to correlate them with candidate genes
which is what the left hand side does
just moving on for reflow to looking at
working at scale now this is the much
shorter part of the presentation just to
illustrate first of all this is very
much a thing we've learned with the
genomics England partnership from one or
two other collaborations similarly and I
just summarized here the genomics
England 100,000 genomes the goals of the
project to bring benefit to patients to
create ethical and transparent programs
to enable scientific discovery number
three and also to really stimulate the
development of the of the industry and
this illustrates some key features of
what we have done in partnership with
genomics England and the NHS is to
develop a program which focuses on
cancer and rare genetic disease it
absolutely epitomizes the paradigms I
showed you at the beginning of this talk
they are not exactly low-hanging fruit
but they are the group of patients most
likely to benefit and where we can learn
more about them we now have an either
accredited workflow for this entire
process for the whole genome sequencing
through two annotated genomes the
interpretation is not yet in that's
position and the data are delivered
securely and electronically to the
genomics England data center to be
utilized for clinical analysis and also
aggregation and interpretation this is
the workflow you see briefly the
genomics England have put together a
workflow it starts with the patient
and the patient is seen at a genomic
medicine center and the sample then goes
into a center field in the illumine our
facility or now it's been transferred to
the Hingston facility next to Sanger in
a purpose-built facility and beds to the
data center in in in England which
provide stores the genome and gives
access for interpretation and you can
see both the sample flow and the data
flow in this process just to zoom in on
the sequencing process for a moment
because this has been an area of
significant concern how do we handle all
the data how do you converge from a
research one-off process to a highly
scaled fully monitored process this
illustrates very briefly the workflow
from left to right from DNA to library
formation to sequencing to delivery and
then eventually deletion of the data
when it's no longer required
at the Jaypee generation site but the
many steps are really governed by so
many steps in QC and this is the point I
really wanted to make here this is now
an industrial process most of the time
is spent looking at all the steps to
look at the passing and failing QC to
ensure that every genome really does
come through the pipeline and is
high-quality and is suitable for use and
that's part of the ISO accreditation
process to govern this but it requires a
complex industrial process management
through laboratory information and also
analysis information systems limbs and
aims which we can discuss more at some
point in the future finally just to
touch on progress there's some 13,000
samples have been delivered the majority
of rare genetic disease not least
because of the additional challenges of
working with real-world cancer samples
and this project includes both genomics
England and earlier pilot at the
University of Cambridge or you can which
is one where we are really fortunate to
learn many of the lessons with a more
local collaboration and the building of
the bottom illustrates one other
important point not just a purpose-built
facility but this was a Wellcome Trust
contribution so this is other sources of
support coming to help the project along
with the building of the early buildings
between campus finally to draw
conclusions first I'll show you once
again the side of the clinical ecosystem
just to remind us that while I've taken
in some detail in some areas to the the
details of what the individual bases are
reading out and how we align the read
and check for accuracy in every genome
this is all part of the process this is
all within one of those colored arrows
this is generating one piece of data one
piece of patient information which is
installed either the entire genome or as
I mentioned the portable GB CF is
perhaps the more portable version of an
individual's genome which gets stored in
a knowledge base and then gets
aggregated and I showed you examples
where researchers are using aggregated
genomes to do essentially
straightforward things like identifying
CNB's in the population that we couldn't
see before and these are very
straightforward and valuable uses of
aggregate DNA information and of course
they're much more big challenge is to
aggregate the clinical information
alongside that and be able to perform
really good genome and phenome
interpretation analyses on aggregate
genomes to really help our clinical
interpretation of variation in the
genome finally just to summarize the
next steps if you will just some of them
of course there are many next steps in
this whole process it's important to
reiterate that among others the genomics
England project is there to demonstrate
the utility of whole genome sequencing
and perhaps to evaluate the utility of
whole genome sequencing for cancer and
for rare genetic disease clearly we're
still looking at the relative value of
this as part of an integrated system and
how it compares to other approaches to
gaining genome sequence information from
individuals but suffice to say some of
the benefits of the whole genome
sequence despite the size of the data
which I hope I've talked to you a little
bit about and the technical challenges
actually it's a very simple workflow and
it really is one test fits all and I
think a confident that the whole genome
sequencing approach really is the way to
a very high diagnostic yield once you
have all the information you can
interpret it if you only go for some of
the information you don't know if the
answer is in that information or not and
that's why I put forward a simple
philosophy for for whole genome
sequencing I've mentioned aggregation of
data we need to learn how to do that
much better and that's scale and we also
need them to look at the in
act on health care to build economic
models and initiate the reimbursement
from health care system we have some
interesting collaborations going on in
England of course it's a state-funded
health system in the u.s. it is not and
so reimbursement is a very different
question and requires different evidence
datasets to actually help decide about
the value utility for reimbursement and
we have some instant collaborations
going on in that regard with particular
with rare genetic disease at the moment
but possibly soon with cancer as well
I'll just mention one of the other
interesting challenges of course is that
some people have said that well as you
can diagnose so much more it's going to
cost so much more to follow up all this
information and treat the patient that's
a very important element to take into
account when looking at the economic
models and how they impact healthcare
the converse of calls to the advantage
you're much more likely to get a precise
and hopefully correct diagnosis in more
cases which ought to make a difference
in a positive way I've mentioned
ecosystems I've not mentioned other
sources of data which are very important
have touched on whole genome and panels
and circulating tumor DNA I haven't
mentioned RNA data which we because do
reckon is very important in cancer
analysis and the ability to look at
information shared across networks
really to enable national adoption and
international adoption requires this
continued concerted effort to build this
very model of a illustrate at the bottom
of this slide I just finished with a
list of names for acknowledgments
particularly knowledge both all the
colleagues in illumine are and there are
many more who are not listed there but
also very important their collaborators
my group and much of alumini works
almost entirely through these
collaborations and very key
collaborators are listed there in
various ways who have contributed to
individual disease studies or the
scaling process or the accuracy of
genomes and variant calling how to look
at cancer and so on and so forth so I'd
like to extend my thank you to those
acknowledgments and also thank you for
listening to this presentation thank you
so much David for such an informative
talk we do have a number of questions
but before we start on those I want to
remind our audience how you can submit
your questions if you can go ahead and
submit
than by typing them into the Q&A box
which you can find on the green Q&A
button on the left hand side of the
presentation screen okay so first
question and DNA mutations were well
covered however I'm curious if you think
that histone modifications or DNA
methylation could be relevant to cancer
diagnostics good question I'm sure it
can be I think one of the reasons that I
emphasize the study of DNA mutations is
quite simply we know more about them
it's a very extensively studied field
and of course with all these areas we're
building on prior research our ability
to understand the mutations really
predicates what we're going to search
for first I think we understand much
less about methylation at the moment
there are some interesting and
compelling insights emerging from
methylation patterns and we have some
collaborations going on on a smaller
scale to look at methylation Xin whole
genomes of cancer patients of our own of
our collaborators to see if we can gain
some insights or help them to gain
insights it's worth reflecting in the
case of methylation in terms of DNA
methylation you mentioned histone
methylation but I'm going more on the
DNA methylation at the moment is that
actually because there are ah there are
forms of methylated bases which are
really previously undetected and mainly
been discovered a few years ago so
though the work of Shankar brother
subrahmanyam for example the celexa
founder has actually uncovered the
importance of hydroxy methylation so we
are faced we're looking at methylation
and hydroxy methylation and other rare
modification of DNA so it's very much a
research area I think at the moment in
terms of what are we looking at are we
even looking at the right thing and once
we have that and it clearly the power to
sequence large amounts of DNA and
methylated DNA can be more rapidly
transferred into beginning to look at
the clinical information there are
others I'm sure in the audience who know
much more about the clinical information
of methylation and I do I certainly look
forward to exploring their theory and
much more so there is another question
related to epigenetics and epigenomics
when will the power of genetics and
genomics be turned to that I guess if
it's still in the research phase it's
still a little while away
I think that's right I think I think
because it's in research different
people will take different views as to
when or how to address the question
there are some small regions of the
genome people have looked at individual
positions for methylation status and if
there's a definite test which really
correlates well on a single part of the
genome there's every reason to go ahead
and start to look at that in a more
clinical situation I expect there are
already examples of map that I'm not
aware of but it is clearly going to be
different for different projects and so
another question when focusing on
somatic mutation studies is it
appropriate to process normal versus
infected tumor tissue sample or only
tumor tissues tumor normal versus tumor
yeah appropriate to process tumor normal
versus infected tumor tissue okay
still much already infected comes in but
let me ask the tumor normal versus tumor
question I think yes clearly we derive a
great deal of benefit from looking at
the normal as well as the two-month in
every in every patient we do find the
sensitivity to eliminate germline
mutations from our putative somatic
mutation panel requires that exact match
for optimal subtraction we don't want to
be looking at somatic mutation
collections where a significant number
of the mutations may still be germline
we actually want to know that we are
looking at relations about absent from
the normal DNA of that same individual
and so the tumor normal pair is very
important and so this next one we can
probably talk about for quite a while
what are the current major challenges to
use genome sequencing as a common
diagnostic tool for large patient
population it's the genomic england
question and in particular i should
emphasize genomic england project is a
pilot it is not a population scale yet I
think we reckon that perhaps on five to
ten fold the scale of this project would
be required if we were to address the
same groups of patients
Trudie population-level I think clearly
on the positive side we've already made
leaps in terms of the cost and
efficiency and I'd like to say the
quality of the sequence information as
well it certainly does provide many good
diagnoses we continue to work on the
areas that could be improved as I've
already mentioned in the tool so cost
data generation perhaps becoming a very
viable proposition and the cost of it
falling well within reasonable budgets
on a per capita basis compared to the
amount of money that's being spent on
other aspects of a particular disease
for example so cost can still reduce of
course and that's an important area that
as demand increases one wants to make
this kind of a safe all the more
available and not limited by cost the
quality is extremely important we
maintain that the other areas of course
are outside the central core that the
sequencing engine and these are areas
where we work very much with our
collaborators to examine it the ability
i've already mentioned to collect
sufficient good-quality DNA to start the
process off so we've had to completely
re-examine how the formalin-fixed
process is done it's been done that way
for a hundred years or more but we need
to change it now because there's a new
demand for it or do we move away from
FFP
these are big fundamental essentially
roadblocks to the process because you do
want every cancer patient to benefit at
least you want every cancer patient not
to be excluded simply because their
sample wasn't good enough you at least
want it to be a choice that it is not
the best test to apply to that patient
instead downstream as well I think I've
mentioned the ongoing process to resolve
the data management challenges shrinking
to a portable genome scaling up
cloud-based infrastructure deciding
whether this is going to be in a public
cloud or private which substantially
changes where you have to invest your
infrastructure effort and of course the
entire process of interpretation that's
a long one I think what I've hopefully
showed to you is the early signs the
glimmers of diagnostic yield being
significant for a significant number of
patients and any one patient some have
been waiting 16
for an answer cancers have actually been
turned around as a result of a cryptic
rearrangement that couldn't be detected
that was eventually detected by whole
genome and dictated a change in
treatment resulting in significant
remission so these anecdotes are real
they can be accessed and we do want to
really remove these roadblocks so they
really can become accessible to more and
more patients when in turn we will then
learn more and more to continue to
increase the diagnostic yield in the
case of cancer of course there's another
whole area of difficulty with rare
genetic disease a diagnosis is there as
a very suitable endpoint a very good
endpoint with cancer of course well you
already know you've got cancer it's how
you treat it and what the prognosis is
and this is a more complex
interpretation problem which is going to
take longer to resolve but one way to do
it is to stimulate it with high-quality
systematically collected data in the
first place in that all-important
knowledgebase so that we can really
begin to look at these other hurdles
that need to be overcome if whole genome
sequencing or any large-scale sequencing
is to gain maximal use in a population
setting so you talked quite a bit about
cancer there and gave them some a lot of
examples in your talk so there's a
question that says given that genetics
and genomics tend to be currently
focused on cancers could you comment on
which diseases will be the next areas of
intense study great question and that
list left out the rare genetic disease
which I hope is of course a given as
well but it's very important I think if
you look formally at the involvement of
some genetic factor be it a risk factor
or modifier or a pharmacogenetic variant
there is some genetics in almost every
condition some of them may never achieve
real significance the very
multifactorial disease is perhaps the
better way to manage it is to work more
directly with with lifestyle and
measurements and modification but the
fact remains that genetics and genetic
factors are influential in many diseases
as we collect more data through studies
like this we will actually improve the
predictive value of genetics for some of
these conditions if I was to pick out a
particular area which is of interest
I think anyone who's looking at a
particular disease type I'll pick out
the cardiac conditions for a moment
because the cardiac conditions actually
how embrace a spectrum of some Mendelian
conditions through to some very
multifactorial conditions with strong
environmental factors but therefore if
we start to look at the cardiac
conditions and sift out the Mendelian
ones and find the genes which are
important which may also have minor
effects in the more complex conditions
we can begin to gradually use the the
accessibility of the entire genome to
actually dissect out the different
genetic components and begin to measure
what the contributions are as well as
finding ones which are previously not
seen because we were using a more
targeted approach previously so I think
there are conditions like that and many
conditions do have Mendelian phenocopy
which may or may not give insights for
the cause of the other complex
conditions but there is a rich area for
this section of the genetic components
through whole genome which would involve
a great deal of time but I do think
these datasets promise to give
investigators or experts in these common
and complex diseases a great deal more
to work with in terms of finding
candidates that can then respond to and
D perhaps require the development of
more refined statistical tools to
analyze the data in the first place okay
so staying around the rare disease as a
question asking what are the challenges
in making a diagnosis for a rare genetic
disease one of the challenges I should
first say I'm not a clinical geneticist
so I've not done it myself in practice
but I can certainly reflect on a few of
the challenges I think clearly the
ability to ask the right questions of an
undiagnosed disease we're talking right
here I guess for a moment where we don't
know we might be looking at a mutation
an existing gene but we don't know which
gene it is or we might be looking
potentially as a mutation and
never previously been involved in a
disease these are two different but also
both quite difficult problems I think
it's it's big it's understanding how to
address the challenge it is important to
look at all the candidates from a
previously been involved in disease it's
also important to look at generic
questioning of the information am i
dealing with an autosomal recessive am i
dealing with a de novo have i examined
the parents in the case of demonstrating
a de novo and looking at the different
ways in which one can address the
question not an easy approach to
describe or even for me to describe
especially others in the audience will
be better better qualified than I am but
I think that the bottom line must be
that the process by which these people
are addressing these problems is
successful because undiagnosed diseases
involving novel genes and mutations that
are not straightforward to find in the
first place
are actually being interpreted and
forming a very convincing diagnosis and
or stimulating functional follow-up I
think while the interesting things is
also that if a new gene is discovered a
colleague of mine who works with me Ryan
Tapp in very early studies of a
leukodystrophy family discovered a gene
that was not previously implicated in
disease but that then led to a search
for is this one right or wrong is it is
it right or not and within months they
then had several more cases of the same
phenotype with mutations in the same
gene and that's how this process moves
from being very difficult and very
uncertain for the first case you think
you've got it but have you really then
to build up the either functional or in
this case population-based confirmation
that the first finding albeit uncertain
can really open up a new area
investigation that can very rapidly lead
to confirming the discovery and actually
making it learn much easier for future
cases of the same phenotype patients
like me and I which is becoming
something of a phrase to be more easily
interpreted that's how the knowledge
base grows in a very simple way from the
rare genetic disease example so on to a
slightly different track now and can you
comment on the utility of using G was in
combination of whole exome sequencing as
a lower
cost option two whole genome sequencing
talking about combination of G while
studies and excellent studies versus
whole genome a--'s and lower-cost option
I'm not sure I'm done really well the
questions trying to go though okay if
the question I would like to make direct
contact we could have it more of a
dialogue on okay it appears that the
genome mutation signatures indicating
exposure has potential application in
public and global health settings are
you aware of any research or work in
this area I guess there are loads of
sort of not population but large scale
genome studies that are happening off
the back of genomics England I will do
everything that I said at a very early
stage if I think we're talking about
expect cancer exposure the signatures of
exposure in cancers the smoking and the
UV inside yeah they just say T no
mutation signatures you know mutation
signatures let's assume it's that and I
would really again refer them to our
collaborators people have gone beyond
our collaborations so particularly my
extracting has been one of the people I
know well that is really investigating
importance and signatures I think much
of it is still in research and
observational I think the clinical
significance I think will take some time
but I feel compelled that that
information should be part of a report
so that in the future if people are
looking if aggregates and cases they can
take that into account in the
interpretation so I guess when it comes
to looking at that data sort of a
related question is will the sequencing
detected in the UK I guess as part of
this gel project will be available to
other parts of the world such as the
u.s. for further research that's a
question for genomics England and I
think I think it's a much wider question
as well because I think I think I would
also say everybody but most people
anyway would see the value of sharing
information of both genome genetic DNA
sequence information RNA sequence
information and also clinical phenotypes
in a way that for the moment has to be
has to address the question of privacy
of the individual so the data has to be
shared
anonymously in an anonymized way so I
think the opportunity is there to do it
and I think one of the great
opportunities that we have starting with
in genomics England certainly the model
is there to share it nationally and to
make it accessible while ensuring the
protection of the data and of the
individual that's the basis on which the
consent is given for each sample to be
donated but undoubtedly the mechanism
for sharing within a particular national
organization is there and indeed the
standardized nature of genome data
output provides an excellent platform
for cross comparison if only phenotypes
were equally standardized and I think
there's now a significant move towards
tackling the much tougher problem of
systematizing phenotypic observations in
a way that the same sorts of patterns
can be drawn using phenotype data as
well as genome data from these cohorts
but you mentioned international as well
and that's a very interesting question
because I think we particularly I think
we at some time ago we polled pediatric
genetic departments would you be willing
to share your data with other hospitals
and of course they say yes because they
may see one case in their lifetime of a
certain type and then they have to make
a judgment on that one case but if they
were to network with a hundred other
hospitals they would suddenly have 10 or
15 cases the same and this networking
process is already happening and there
are there are apps which are encouraging
that communication but clearly to take
that concept further there is great
value in aggregating from multiple
sources because the diseases and the
causes of disease are essentially
probably mostly the same worldwide so it
is absolutely valid to pool the
information in a way which people find
acceptable either with national
boundaries or consent and privacy issues
and it should be done and and certainly
the the very digital nature of DNA
information allows for DNA itself to be
a great currency for real comparisons
between genomes and perhaps that can in
some way help the formalization and
standardization at this data sharing I
think if we can respect national
boundaries or particular ethical
policies or government policies in
differ
countries but nevertheless build the
mechanisms by which those boundaries can
be can be jumped over through
permissions through granting permission
through asking permission whatever it
may be we might not see a single
database for everybody in the world with
a particular disease but we might see a
term which is often used as the
Federation of data and sharing across
boundaries and I think the very fact
that we have mechanisms for data sharing
cloud based computing very fast
communication of course takes away the
technical challenge of this it can
easily be shared
technically the question is how to
structure it in such a way that
everybody find it acceptable and it
doesn't become restrictive to their
final potential gains okay so we have
time for one last question and so
sticking with the ethical and the data
sharing there and how will this project
exactly create an ethical and
transparent program you touched a bit on
the ethics though what about the
transparency as well the transparency
which is a really important part of the
genomics England mission and again
something that they've really taken the
lead on for this project I think quite
simply to put it simply it's not simple
but to put it simply it's quite simply
ensuring very good engagement of the
public the general public and the
professional medical professionals and
so on so that they are aware of what is
being done and why and how and I think
it's very important to reflect on the
fact that it is not even just what you
actually do it's the perception of
what's being done that is important to
be straight and if you're completely
transparent the perception matches the
reality but if there is not transparency
there is fear there is fear of the
unknown what's happening to my data and
I think that's a very important part of
being transparent and that is the public
engagement process explaining what's
happening being very obvious about
protecting the data the consent forms
and the consenting process does reach
does require informed consent I've not
been part of a consenting process but
the ability to make it clear to the
individual so they know what they are
consenting to and what
and half of that data is part of that
transparency just as being very clear
about how they store the data and
various phrases I think stick genomic
kingdom have chosen to store the data in
a private cloud system it is not on the
public cloud so it is free from some of
the risks that are associated with
public clouds and that creates both
perception and a reality that there is a
level of protection and security and
responsibility has been taken from the
data another example is the data is is
is reviewed as it's a reading library
not a lending library you can gain
access to the data and you can read it
you cannot take it away
and so that's perhaps a simple way of
being transparent about how you handle
data by using a very common analogy of
the reading library we can't take
anything out versus the lending library
which is a philosophy employed by the
genomic England data center clearly
these things may change but if we change
to become more accessible it has to be
buy through through essentially the
public being as much involved in that
decision and seeing the benefits versus
the risks and I do see and people have
predicted major changes in social
attitudes to privacy and data people
have already cited the change in privacy
since Facebook and other social media
people are not actually that worried
about privacy or they get hurt and
things move on and clearly we may see
changes but they must be changed between
role of the public the public
understanding of what's being done here
and their acceptance and be part of the
decision making process to actually see
data mail accessible for public good and
for medical use well thank you very much
once again and we did have a number of
questions that we didn't get to so I
really apologize for that do you have
any final comments or takeaway messages
before we wrap up no certainly I hope
that many of you will are stimulated to
see both the challenges and the appetite
to actually help resolve and really
implement this very exciting piece of
technology into healthcare you're not
for a moment suggest that genomes are
the answer to everything but they are
very important
and of every one of us which contributes
to our life and potentially can be
utilized effectively in health care and
I hope that benefit can be realized
really in a population wide scale it
takes all of us and it takes
collaboration and it takes time and I
hope you're very much involved in this
I'd like to thank you all again very
much for your time and today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
from for the next six months and you
will receive an email from Mavericks
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcements on to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
webinar event event thank you very much
for attending thank you once again David
and enjoy the rest of the event